Salam alaikum guys how you doing I'm  with Ali professional former  professional fighter of how many years  15 years 15 years we just had a show  look out for it but we're looking for  many people in your part of the world  Dagestan and other places in Russia  they've been asking me said what's up  with hobby where's he at  maybe he don't understand my english  keep it humble tell him how do you say  it in your language so we can make sure  he got the message  so now la cumbre be put to a progression  a show as a nurse brought on your show  so it gives me a show pop  overly-complicated schmuck artists who  seek to premium islam any factory by  city by tourists annually to Liberty  that shall its most pretty talk about  its name you heard it  hope all you got you the message we hope  to see you soon brother Salam alaykoum  dr. up Carter  you